so uh we are going to talk on the bonus
show today about how terribly donald
trump's social media platform truth
social is doing truth essential yes
truth sensual as some people know it uh
donald trump yesterday spent a bunch of
time on truth social
just flipping out and you can tell
this guy is panicking
this guy realizes the walls are closing
in around him the lawyers he picked from
just seeing them on tv
don't seem to be representing him in the
most
uh coherent and competent way
and donald trump with another one of
these multi-post tirades that used to be
reserved for twitter
until trump was banned trump kicking it
off with the
now emblematic all caps witch hunt with
three exclamation points you know i
actually respect three exclamation
points when i see two
it's a little weird but you know if you
want to do one exclamation point or
three i can get behind that so at least
trump with three exclamation points then
trump posting quote when are the great
agents and others in the fbi
going to say we aren't going to take it
anymore
much as they did when james comey read
off a list of all of crooked hillary
clinton's crimes only to say that no
reasonable prosecutor would prosecute
the wonderful people of the fbi went
absolutely nuts
so comey had to backtrack and do a fake
investigation in order to keep them at
bay the end result we won in 2016 and we
did much better in 2020 but now the left
has lost their minds
that is a wild wild assertion
it's gobbledygook it's a verbal ink blot
well it's a i guess it's a written one
that doesn't make any sense and trump
just not relenting continuing with quote
the raid on my home mar-a-lago
is one of the most egregious assaults on
democracy in the history of our capital
c country
which is by the way
going to places in a very bad way it has
never seen before
and then lastly
back to all caps
invasion of privacy
and again this could be referring to
anything this could be referring to
uh the raid on mar-a-lago itself
this could be referring to what's in the
affidavit i mean with donald trump you
never really know
this is a very
scared
but also incompetent
delusional
and narcissistic individual
and what summer's now suggesting
is that when you take remember trump
never apologizes trump never thinks he
did anything wrong he never takes
responsibility that's been the theme
typical of narcissists
what some are now starting to speculate
is that this
it's always been unhinged but there's
something uniquely unhinged about about
this
that trump now is starting to be the
authoritarian dictator wannabe
narcissist
who is starting to believe
the walls may be closing in around me
and
one of the difficulties
when such people start to believe that
is that i hate to use this analogy
because
i'm not literally comparing people to
animals but
when cornered animals
uh realize they are cornered sometimes
they start to behave in ways that are
extremely out of character unpredictable
erratic and dangerous
and when you take a true narcissist who
never apologizes never admits that he's
done anything wrong and believes he's
always so
he believes he's so much smarter than
everybody else that if you just let him
talk to them he'll talk his way out of
an indictment an investigation whatever
when they start to think wow i really
may be screwed here
all bets are off about what they might
be willing to do and we may well be
getting to that spot with donald trump
the next two months are going to be nuts
the next two months are going to be
truly truly nuts
we're going to take a very quick break
make sure you're following us on
facebook facebook.com davidpakmanshow
and remember uh that wednesday
this wednesday august 31st at 6 pm
eastern we will be doing the members
only town hall if you'd like to
participate sign up at joinpacman.com